-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
Thank you very much.
That was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-That applause lasted longer
than Tom Brady's retirement.
-Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-That's right.
Yesterday, Tom Brady
called off his retirement
and announced
that he will return next season
to play for
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Basically, Brady saw gas prices
and said, "Back to work.
Here we go."
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Tom Brady is back,
and once again,
he made history
as the first person
to ever move to Florida
and unretire.
[ Laughter ]
Brady's retirement
lasted 40 days.
In other words, he pretty much
gave up football for Lent.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he was only retired
for six weeks.
His kids are like,
"Is it something we said?
I, uh..."
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling Brady's gonna
be like one of those bands
that keep going
on their farewell tour.
It's like, "This is our
last tour, this year.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's pumped
that Brady's back.
Well, except for
maybe this guy.
-Hours before
Brady announced his return,
an auction took place
for the football he used
to throw
his final touchdown pass.
The winning bid
was more than $500,000.
-The auctioneer was like,
"Sold to the guy
with really bad timing.
Yeah, there you go.
You got it."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it went from Tom Brady's
last touchdown ball to a ball.
[ Laughter ]
In other sports news,
March Madness
has officially begun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
March Madness!
People -- People also call it
the Big Dance,
the Road to the Final Four,
and Adults Yelling at
College Kids They Don't Know.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I saw that Yale made it
to the tournament this year,
but only 'cause their dad
made a phone call.
[ Laughter ]
Well, switching gears,
Uber just announced
that customers will pay
an additional charge
to help its drivers
offset high gas prices.
Yeah, Uber's adding
a surcharge for gas.
You know it's bad
when the driver shows up
on foot and says,
"Let's take your car."
[ Laughter ]
"That's a nice one."
Yep, things are rough now.
If you want heat or A.C.,
the driver just blows on you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Exhaling heavily ]
Some more business news --
I read that, due to inflation,
Doritos has been putting
five fewer chips in each bag.
[ Laughter ]
And if you noticed the change,
you've got bigger problems
than inflation.
[ Laughter ]
"W-W-What?!
Normally,
there's 48 chips in the bag."
-"I've been robbed!"
-"I'm only counting 43."
[ Laughter ]
-"Mother!"
-Even worse, today, at
the grocery store, I saw this --
one Pringle.
[ Laughter ]
One --
-Just says "Pringle."
-Yeah, Pringle.
-Not Pringles.
Yeah, still hard to get
your hand in there, too.
I don't know why.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's still broken.
-Get this -- today,
Apple released an update
that lets you use Face ID
to unlock your phone
while wearing a mask.
-Ooh.
-Even the guy who bought
Tom Brady's football
was like, "Great timing."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I saw that the TSA
issued a statement
asking spring break travelers
to be respectful.
[ Laughter ]
They tried putting up a sign,
but spring breakers
immediately drew a penis on it.
And they were like,
"All right, all right.
"We get it, we get it.
We get it."
I heard about a man in Florida
who was arrested after
he called 9-1-1 to check
if the meth
that he bought was authentic.
[ Laughter ]
In other words, spring break
has officially sprung.
It's happening.
It's spring break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The guy was so embarrassed,
he sent his friends this emoji.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman in the U.K.
who just turned 102 says
she credits her good health to
Jagerbombs, tequila, and pizza.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, then Prince Charles
was like, "Okay, Mum,
let's get you to bed."
All right,
we have a great show, everyone!